ma verrà tutti ragazzi benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono quello che poi
video
volevo dirvi che era una vita una vita
che non tornavo sono ben and had ragazzi
che questo gioco pazzesco
non so se lo ricordate è semplicemente
io sono uno zombie che deve superare gli
ostacoli è semplicemente questo la
faccenda è che l'ultima volta che ci
hanno sono morto
ma come al 98 vite per finire il suo
livello e sono veramente veramente poche
ve lo dico non so se vi ricordate come
si gioca praticamente tu sei tu siete ma
come parlo io sono questo zombie che
deve superare gli ostacoli molto
semplicemente non è niente di difficile
e mi posso staccare i pezzi per poter
far arrivare i pezzi al posto mio
e la cosa è veramente utile alle volte
tipo adesso ho soltanto 99 vite e
fidatevi che sono ovvero questa maretta
niente devo provare il pack richiama la
mappa si sviluppa in alto madonna il
casinò allora non farò mai motosega alla
pa che tu puoi farlo anche con altre
persone ovviamente nessuno già sto gioco
qui lo faccio solo io e proverò ad
arrivare alla fine ma vi giuro ragazzi
era da una vita che non ci giocava
bellissimo
l'ultimo teste ho fatto video avevo 16
anni non è perduto però madonna ok no
buono buono vuole uno mi sono salvato
perché se così quest'anno maledette
l'importante è che non venga che non mi
si stacchino tutti i pezzi perché sono
poi non riscoprire andava mattina finché
così a posto la gallina vi pare servisse
per per planare non vorrei dire una
cagata hanno addirittura salta più in
alto va bene io il tempismo non siamo
proprio la stessa cosa non so se ve ne
siete accorti però mette anche l'ex
parco demonio allora è facciamo passare
la prima che se non escano dai ok
meraviglioso la gallina ha dato una mano
attenzione è morta sulla limitata alla
gallina maledizione per torino vabbè
prova lanciarmi a questo punto mi lancio
con la testa bilancio co la testa
perfetto se non lo sapete ragazzi la
testa e ve lo dico io è comunque
considerata arrivo importante arrivare
con la testa bosch mail fare io c'è un
finali sto gioco oppure devo andare
avanti a caso che culo vado avanti
finché posso e poi lancio la testa dopo
capito se avete capito il discorso ma io
sì l'ho capitoni va bene ok perché ho
più propulsione con la testa quasi
el'arancio adesso capitolo madonna che
rischio e se solo riuscisse e non ci
arriva purtroppo non ci arriva marco non
ci credo sono vivo lo devo fare un
disastro buono buonissimo perfetto
ok ok allora attenzione non è male non è
male non è male non ne vale non è male
per niente ok non c'è neanche la bomba
non c'è neanche la bomba ma io mica go
addosso e lancio la testa perfetto
adesso proviamo perché non scaricate due
quella di prima era ancora fattibile
quest'anno non penso tu sia in qualche
modo fattibile però proviamoci
mi sa che puoi farla a tempo con altra
gente perché ci sono tre vie quindi
teoricamente poi con i tuoi amici farla
tempo a verona non ho amici il problema
è che non c'è non c'è il check point c'è
poi metteteli che cacchio e quindi cosa
vuol dire non è che posso farlo senza
lasciatelo fare quattro salti sul verde
quello viola no vabbè ragazzi
impossibile senza senza i check point da
parte ci sono delle bombe come le
superano le super ok è da una vita che
non gioco iniziato livelli più difficili
sto pianeta non esistono sono
impossibili e vabbè dai facciamo un
altro livello
perché questo infattibile pochi ragazzi
fa ho scelto la mappa che una delle più
gettonati in assoluto sembra quella di
prima ma non è quella di prima almeno
quello 80 vite infinito tempo let's go
vediamo se scappare proprio di recente
per adesso non male per adesso invece
molto male qua e vedo che comunque stava
palestra utilizzata per dargli editor
vedo che la stessa la conformazione è la
stessa di prima
la difficoltà forse meno speriamo perché
non c'è un check point e manco a pagarlo
in anni quindi non non è possibile
nello spezia poi la vacca non esistono
check point ai ragazzi non fallisce 47
pazzi ma fateli sono difficilissimi da
fare schifo di gente checkpoint parte
che prima ho fatto una provata di quelle
pazzesche non so se riesco di nuovo
e invece ci riesco equa che ho fatto la
provata pazzesca
ecco una roba devo avere il tempismo e
non ho niente di questo
[Musica]
perfetto madonna ragazzi è stato
veramente di guarda mi vorrei fare un
applauso da solo perché è veramente
difficile però sarebbe molto kringe
allora l'ultimo arrivo invece ci sono
arrivato cosa no no no no vi prego vi
prego
ve la dico io perché se non lo sapete
qua ci devi arrivare col corpo non puoi
arrivarci con la testa se non si apre la
porta al check point e qui dietro barca
va
non è che per un bug che riesco a
passare lo stesso aspetta non ci credo
non ci sono passato era un poker
bellissimo lo sfruttatore di bikers
proprio lui la trova
meno male perché non ci sarei mai
arrivato con il corpo come fai
no vabbè ragazzi sarebbe stato
impossibile meno male
meno male che ho sfruttato un bug per
una volta nella vita meno male che ha
funzionato un bug che volevo sfruttare
non succede mai sta cosa
che culo va bene ragazzi allora ce l'ho
fatta senza pagare niente vediamo se le
sue cose che io che fin qua tutto a
posto
fin qua tutto a posto tutto ciò che
veramente incasinato come la morte non
so perché ho smesso di farlo ok adesso
mi sono ricordato perché ho smesso di
farlo allora porca vacca positivo
sbagliato lido bisogno di più
propulsione come faccio
[Musica]
ecco ce l'ho fatta
proprio lui col corpo alla volta senza
neanche il bug madonna ce l'ho fatta
c'è poi ragazzi c'è point non mi fate
scherzi e allora a posto a posto
recupero pure il mio corpo e come arrivo
come arrivo con arrivo e non quando
lancia la testa per forza e qua qua se
no non poteva arrivare qui quindi se c'e
robe no testa
siete stupidi perché non ci potevo
arrivare no la mia se salta una volta
poi non puoi non risponda e storicamente
quindi forse mi devo sacrificarmi
ma neanche dai mica qua come faccio ok
ok dai dai
proprio lui proprio lui la risolve e non
solo anche come la prima parte era la
più difficile
fortunatamente poi dopo si è calmata un
attimo la situazione perché sono ok ma
guarda meno male che all'inizio era il
più difficile
così almeno fatto un po avanti perfetto
mi chiamo e su cui credo che sia ragazzi
il gioco del parco definitivo
cioè non esistono meglio di questo per
come è fatto scherzavo una mezzala
facessi normale no no aspettate proprio
così perché normale era ancora più
difficile dai
a posto ma porca vacca ok ok ora devo
fare un casino
[Musica]
no sì non ci credo ok però vedreste
disco di sfruttare il bug di prima e lo
fa proprio lui
tutto bene quel che finisce bene le cose
a posto fin qua tutto a posto fin qua
tutto a posto
minchia non ci arriverò mai madonna e ce
l'ho fatta
oddio cioè c'è poi a posto no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no che è
stato fermo sei ore per quale motivo non
lo so meraviglioso ce l'ho fatta e sono
stupito di me stesso in stavolta non una
sola volta una volta sono verte su
stupito di me stesso
leger madonna come mi sono salvato
perché non avevo più velocità due check
point così alla sua porta e raffinata e
questo ce l'ho fatta serve bravissimo
ragazzi di casa bravo questa e la
proprio difficile capirci persone volete
un altro perché comunque benedette da un
botto e non lo gioco se non avesse la
visita del santo e portarne un altro 6
viene piaciuto ragazzi consentono certo
momento è un bel mi piace anche vari
social che come nevi adottata
descrizione certo ci si chiede e noi
come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
è la ragazza
[Musica]